stage robert muller the former director
of the FBI he's currently a partner at
Wilmer Hale
and we're going to talk just exactly
about what what businesses can do when
they recognize a cyber threat and the
measures that they should put in place
please welcome Bob see you you've had
the opportunity to listen to a few
panels this morning and the discussion
with with the Admiral is your biggest
when are we gonna get the cybersecurity
[Applause]
what is what is the biggest issue facing
corporate America right now when it
comes to cybersecurity
the lack of understanding of the area
and the issues and a policy or practice
generally of CEOs and top management to
delegate problems and not recognizing
the depth of the challenges and how
swiftly a cyber attack and cut your
reputation down and not anticipate not
knowing this arena it's very difficult
for them to come up with an
organizational structure that will
immediately elevated elevate those facts
that would lead to substantial damage in
the corporation I I looked what happened
to me in the bureau and one of the
mistakes I made was in upgrading our
information technology for instance and
you how is that a mistake well because I
didn't ask the hard questions you rely
on persons on the one hand you have the
technologists on the other hand you have
the business practice the agents in the
light you have to come up with a new
case management system you delegate that
they tell you what's going to happen
it's going to happen it doesn't happen
and you look back on you reflect and say
i delegated an area where I should have
been personally involved it goes back to
what Admiral Rogers was saying you have
to take responsibility at the top
I think too few senior management know
and understand that particular issue and
secondly are uncertain as to how you
address it I mean think about you know
if you're CEO of a company you might be
a terrific manager you might really
understand sales you might really
understand your product but you don't
necessarily understand technology but
you have to understand it to the point
that you can know and understand where
the money is going to in adopting the
new technology upgrading and new
technology you just cannot leave it to
others you have to be sufficiently
knowledgeable and understanding and ask
the hard questions and I bought myself
for not asking hard questions they said
you know come a particular point in time
you've come in to turn a switch and this
new case management system will work in
my mind I said hey you know really you
know how that's gonna work and obly it
did not so we had to go back restructure
and get it done we got it done but it's
one of those areas and it it should have
taken more of my personal time to make
certain that it was on track well there
are a lot of questions surrounding just
exactly what's the responsibility of
business what's the responsibility of
government when it comes to protecting
the cyber arena arena how does that
break down where do you see it well a
couple of things I think on one side the
federal government has to do a we're
doing a better job but even a better job
in sharing information between NSA FBI
and Department of Homeland Security
and then on the other side the business
community needs to do a better job
coming up with vehicles for sharing
intelligence amongst themselves but also
sharing that intelligence with the
federal government if the legislation
that is contemplated up on the hill
which gives a safe harbor to companies
providing information to the federal
government relating to breaches in the
light passes that would be tremendously
helpful but there has to be an exchange
of information between the federal
government on one side and
a private-sector on the other side and
when it implies a lot of trust a company
has to be willing to say okay I'm gonna
turn over all this respect you have they
have some control over what is turned
over they can protect their intellectual
property and still turn over the
information is necessary to determine
what's a piece of malware that was
recently used is that if in fact their
networks and networks is infecting other
networks I would say that in the wake of
September 11th one of the things we had
to do was develop relationships with
other partners in order to be successful
principal partner state local law
enforcement we could not have been
successful in thwarting attacks without
the Joint Terrorism Task Forces and
state and local law enforcement in the
cyber arena it's the private sector we
are not going to be successful and
getting ahead of this curve without
having mechanisms for the sharing of
intelligence in the private sector
sharing it amongst the federal agencies
and then having that information shared
amongst those that's currently working
our private companies sharing enough
information their episodically most of
it I would say is tremendously informal
there has to be a more formal process of
sharing in sectors and and thanks to the
Department of Homeland Security and
particular sectors there is a growing
body of capability of integrating the
intelligence in particular sectors
particularly particularly the financial
sector for instance why in particular
financial sector because they have gone
further than most others and setting up
capabilities that allow the sharing of
information so you're at Wilmer Hale now
if a client comes to you and says I
think there's been a breach what do you
advise them to do is you know the next
course of action well then you're on the
right side as it was quick post breach
one would have hoped they were taking
certain steps pre be full reach but post
breach of a most important thing
determines who's in charge you cannot
just go and say to your CIO or your
chief security officer say okay you're
in charge a substantial breach
implicates first of all your own people
your customers one of the first steps
that you have to take is determine what
exactly was a breach how devastating
wasn't how do you control it and that
requires forensics and too often there
is a delay between the breach and
getting forensics onboard to tell you
exactly what happened and you can't
notify or you don't think you can notify
it until you know exactly what happened
and consequently you gotta address the
forensics you got to address the fact
that the SEC is going to want to know if
it's a material breach
perhaps the Department of Justice
they're five or six or seven entities
that have to be looked at in order to
determine what the next steps are and
then you have to orchestrate bringing
together those particular strains out of
responsibility in such a way that you
move quickly and you have somebody in
charge who is not necessarily just a
technician not just a human resources
person but somebody has the ear of the
CEO what does a company need to do to
inform the people that have been
affected I mean you look at the target
example and target did not immediately
come out and tell customers in fact
there's no law that requires them to do
so the banks need to let the customers
know that they're their credit cards may
have been violated but target doesn't
need to do so any any guidance there for
corporate America in terms of
communicating with the people effective
I think one of the things
circumstances you see is that when there
is a substantial breach well the first
things that comes to mind particularly
General Counsel's the litigation it's
coming down the pike which is an aspect
of it but the litigation is not as
important as reputational damage
particularly if you're somebody has
products or or sell things and the
reputational damage
can weigh out weigh in considerations
related to the inevitable litigation
will come down the pike and so
prioritizing to preserve that
reputational damage by notification but
notification with a fairly firm
understanding of what happened is
tremendously important and then assuring
your public your customers that's not
going to happen you resolved it takes
leadership from above
it can't be leadership two or three or
low levels down so leadership basically
it sounds like overall defining the
person who's in charge and that person
who's in charge really having a firm
grasp of the the technology space
overall it is critical yes but you need
not only it's again like developing the
IT you need the technical aspects of it
that's part of it but you also need the
people aspects of it particularly when
the most serious contemplated breach
would be the insider threat the snowden
threat because corporate america deals
with that just just as the NSA has to
deal with something like what you don't
you don't find and we talk here today
and you'll continue to talk about
protecting networks there won't be a
tremendous amount of emphasis placed on
the biggest vulnerability is that
disgruntled employee who has
administrators rights who is unhappy and
then can do the damage from within and
so that you have to identify very
quickly and address it from the human
resources point of view i mean are there
are there mechanisms to do that let me
tell you there's a there's an extreme at
the in the government for instance
everybody the FBI has to take a
polygraph periodically every five years
every five years you look at your
financials you look at what NSA or what
Admiral Rogers indicated was happening
at NSA in terms of the stretchers and so
on one end of the spectrum you have
the auditing of downloads you have the
focus on individuals or financial
situations the polygraphs for NSA at
that for the secrets that they keep and
the other end you have companies that
say well we trust our employees and if
we instituted anything along those lines
it would indicate a distrust and not
only would our employees be unhappy but
they'd be so unhappy they'll go to some
other employer where this is not
required place in between you've got a
draw why mm-hmm it's it's it's a
challenging balance let me ask you about
something that that the Admiral and I
spoke a bit about and that is the
concern that we're getting ourselves
into a protectionist environment as far
as our global economy is concerned China
accusing us of spying on them we're of
course saying China's spying on us and
it's this back and forth
the net result and the fear among many
in the tech community is that we are
gonna lose business opportunities as a
result of all this this worry how do you
see that playing out as we're in this
sort of infantile stage of cyber
hyper-awareness I do think in the short
term the disclosures will affect the
relationship but I would say affect
their relationship I like the Admiral
think though that our technology is such
as an out-and-out does everybody else
and certainly in Europe and elsewhere
and Europe and the West ultimately we
will prevail despite the efforts of
companies to bolster developing
internal corporations to take over some
of the some of the that information
capability in China it was inevitable in
any event China wishes wants our
technology and to the extent that they
can get our technology and build their
own that has been their goal for forever
in a day and it's you know this may be a
little bump in the road but again I
think it was either inevitable or our
technology as such as that large
communities of persons are going to
gravitate to it and this will be as I
say a bump in the road
is it naive for other countries to say
oh you know you guys are looking at us
or is it naive of us to say oh you're
looking at us there are a number of
countries out there some of whom have
been our greatest critique errs who have
their own internal capabilities that are
not necessarily known to their
population often not known and
understood by their Parliament's the one
thing that has been missing from the
coverage of this is the fact that we are
the only country that I'm aware of where
we have a court that passes on the
request to intercept an individual in
the national security realm that being
the FISA Court and that provides a
protection that no other country has
whether it be Scandinavia the UK be the
Home Secretary France or elsewhere there
is not a court between the prosecutor
and the investigator and the
interception that passes on the probable
cause with and so we have safeguards
that I think are in some ways very much
more advanced than you would find in
many of those countries who criticized
us so heavily but at the same time as
our technology so advanced that you know
assuming we've checked off all those
boxes we can gather much not so much
different and in fact there are
countries around who I have far less
strictures on what their national
security agencies can do
yeah NSA whenever NSA picks up an
American citizen they either drop it or
I'll get a memo the FBI will get a memo
if there's some criminal conduct and the
memo will say we intercepted individual
a or individual number one who appears
to be involved in this criminal activity
don't indicate the name of the person we
look at it see if it's something we
would investigate and then we have to
send another memo back to NSA saying yes
we're interested investigating and give
us information
now when the cyber attacks were a
substantial concern day in and day out
this somewhat burdensome procedure was
frustrating in terms of getting the
information you may need but nonetheless
we have that protection there we have
that wall there that protects the
surveillance of American citizens that
you would not find and I don't know any
other country um I spoke to the head of
a company the other day who had been
working closely with the FBI and as a
result of the sort of Intel that they
were gathering in the cyber world they
were able to basically figure out that
five hundred million dollars had been
siphoned off from various bank accounts
across the globe and one of the things
that this individual was citing was the
cooperation there between a private
company and in this case the FBI is that
the way in the future is that how the
FBI and and you know you were the
director of the FBI I mean is that the
future for going after these cyber
criminals yes and anticipating cyber
criminals and one of the things we tried
to do was take a particular sector the
financial sector you take the exchanges
for instance when we think there'd be
targets and what we want to do is as
we've done in other areas I go out and
develop relationships with the security
individuals in those particular whether
it be exchanges or financial
institutions so that they know who in
the FBI has proficiency in this area and
a name with a fate a face with a name
and so if there is a breach and they
know who to call
the FBI agents do it know what they're
doing know what evidence they'll need
from their log books and the like so
develop that relationship in
anticipation of the probability at some
point in time that there would be a
breach so we're doing much more than we
are
also understand the responsibility for
disclosing to victims the fact that they
have been breached or hacked into by the
chinese the russians iranians or others
and we had several thousand last year of
you knock on the door and say did you
know that the Chinese or the Russians
were in your networks and fault majority
of them did not know that but it's our
responsibility to alert persons to that
in terms of the FBI personnel that you
have now is there much being done in
terms of training them to understand
technology yeah one of the things in the
wake of September 11th one of the
priorities was that the organization be
able to know understand and utilize the
digital arena and in the wake of
September 11th we also understood that
our traditional hiring patterns of
lawyers accountants former military and
former law enforcement was inadequate to
a new world I think so quite obviously
we opened up the language in the wake of
a counterterrorism we have opened up to
the language area specialists in the
wake of the anthrax attacks we found we
had almost a thousand interview
interviews to be done persons who had in
some way been utilizing anthrax and we
didn't have the chemists or the
biologists to be able to do that kind of
interview so we have hired chemists
biologists and like likewise in the
cyber arena a software hearses from
software firms hardware firms computer
scientists we over the last 12 years
have been hiring up in that arena but
also we have a number of persons that
are not at the top level quality in
terms of capabilities but just under it
around around the country we have by now
way over a thousand individuals around
the country are capable of doing these
investing
but let me make one point when I say
that and that is we focus on protecting
networks with tell me how we focus on
this cyber aspect but we cannot forget
that behind every cyber attack there is
a warm body sitting behind the keyboard
and part of understanding and addressing
this is identifying those persons who
are responsible in dining them in
certain cases or wrestling them and
convicting them as we have throughout
the years one of the problems in this
area is you don't know what the outside
of an intrusion whether it's a Chinese
the Russians whether it's organized
crime here or Russia or it's at 18 year
old sitting up at a bedroom someplace
who has the capabilities to merrily I
mean can you say there is a particular
part of this world where we're seeing
the majority of cyber crime originate I
I wouldn't I don't think I've talked
about in sort of the gross terms I would
say on the one hand you have I've
divided into five vectors the first is
the hacktivists the anonymous LulzSec
those individuals are tremendously
capable that aren't necessarily stealing
information for stealing information
sake but want to embarrass you
secondly you have the criminals the
targets and yeah and the like thirdly
you have the theft of intellectual
property and the espionage now fourth
you have the you have the terrorists and
potential use of cyber by terrorists and
fifth you have the military using cyber
as several years ago when the Russians
sent the tanks into Georgia they knocked
out Georgia's command and control before
they sent the tanks out those are the
five vectors of threats that we in the
bureau would deal with Wow
it is but you have to in order to be
successful and addressing those threats
you have to know who's seen behind that
keyboard is it somebody from anonymous
or is it that Russian hacker and of
Russia or the UK and it takes a yes but
it takes a combination of investigative
skills which we have traditionally have
coupled with the use of this new medium
in the cyber arena and so you can't
dismiss
the necessity of identifying the persons
identifying where the servers are
identified the building of that persons
in tracing an IP and IP address to a
particular building to a particular
apartment to a particular individual go
back to preventive measures again it's I
think target had have been every retail
CEO every CEO is just nightmare you know
and I can remember talking off record
with with some people that said you know
look in some ways therefore you know
that could have been that you know
there's there's no reason that that now
as forgive me we're gonna see a little
bit on target coming up and we've got
the Business Week team that did the
investigation into the story as it
turned out there were actually a number
of things that that company could have
should have done to prevent what
eventually happened but you know it's
20/20 hindsight right I mean it's it's
easier to look back after the fact what
is it that that corporations especially
corporations that are dealing with
consumer information and you talked
about it earlier once you want to lose
that trust on the consumer that's a very
very hard thing to regain what do they
need to be doing to make sure that they
don't become like target oh yeah you
have to again think beyond just the
technology you have to do you have
another insider that is a threat so it's
human resources okay how do you identify
that how do you monitor downloads of
your information you have to map the
networks and determine whether the
vulnerability of Baldur milner abilities
in those networks and then identify
particular eyes tool to address those
vulnerabilities and the vulnerabilities
and company a may be far different and
vulnerabilities and Company B and
develop a structure and a strategy that
that identifies those vulnerabilities
and closes those vulnerabilities and at
the same time underst
and that you will be breached at some
particular point in time what is going
to happen when you get the the email
saying hey look we've got a breach here
what are you going to who you may turn
to and who is going to be in charge of
orchestrating their various elements in
the corporation's to make certain that
you're addressing this particularly
sitio then is a pretty important job it
is it's a very important job but it also
is a specialized job let me let me segue
into two state concerns I mean we've
talked about sort of corporate America
and their concerns what about state
concerns I mean you know we keep hearing
of all these cyber threats we've seen
this huge improvement in technology that
people are able to access what's the
danger for us I mean if you were still
at the FBI today what would be your
concern for the country from the state
perspective well there there are a
couple of cyber issues that rise to the
forefront actually probably three first
and this is in terms of enhanced
capabilities of the cyber criminals that
is the wiper use of a wiper virus to
wipe out information on hard drives in
2012 as I'm sure you're aware the aramco
the Saudi Arabian oil company was
infected by a virus that wiped out
30,000 hard drives and that's the first
large-scale incident we have seen but I
think anybody who's in this business who
is responsible for the corporate
security is concerned by what would
happen if you it's not just a denial
service attack which is a problem it's
not exfiltration of information it is
wiping out information that you may or
may not have a backup for that can
disrupt wholly disrupt your your company
that is a problem
if second is the financial arena and the
ability to address attacks that would I
Financial you know banks have been
targets of denial of service attacks for
a substantial period of time and but if
it increases in
of the capabilities and the effect on
information that's tremendously
problematic and the last is internally
the SCADA systems that run much of our
industrial industrial con industrial
complexes and the the fact that those
systems were built at a time where the
internet was open and have very very few
precautions and it is very difficult and
expensive to tighten down SCADA system
to the point where you could totally
preclude individuals from getting in
what is what does that mean I mean what
could they do I think there have been
displays on what can happen if you get
in and the end of the computer system
and with a couple of shifts of controls
have a water station blow up the power
grid adversely affected
there was a attack on a power station in
California several months ago I think
you probably are aware it was actually
more of a a on the ground firing of
weapons at the at the power station and
but it's worrisome in the sense that
someone took upon themselves to
understate to undertake a orchestrated
attack on a power station if you had a
hacker with sufficient skills that would
be a substantial threat to us
well here we aren't talking about what
corporate America needs to do better to
prevent themselves from being in a bad
situation what did the country mean to
do better to prevent anything as such as
what you just described
well I on the one hand as I said it's
important for us to recognize that as we
learn in September 11th so we have to
apply here and that is the best defenses
sharing of information we did not share
information before September 11th there
were walls between CIA FBI and even
within the FBI until those walls were
removed when Keith Alexander was charged
NSA Janet Napolitano and DHS we met to
make certain we understood the lanes and
the row
and how we can share information with
understanding the strictures that you
have in terms of those sharings but
again on the other hand the success is
going to be a large part dependent on
finding ways to utilize and harness the
talents that capabilities the
intelligence of the private sector to
address terrorism and aside with rain
what have you seen from the private
sector have you seen a willingness to do
that because at the same time you know
as as I've talked about people are
worried about turning over information
there are models out there where in a
particular area 60 70 80 corporations
will come together to set up an exchange
so that you can exchange particular
intelligence and then throw that
intelligence over the transom to the FBI
and so there are models out there that
are just beginning to grow that we can
follow the other the only other point
I'd make is you have to take into
account that the American public wants
us to understand and know what
information is going to the federal
government and what that information is
being used for and so it's important to
have transparency in terms of the
architecture that is established for
this information sharing but you have to
have the information I mean that well I
mean so I'll give you a recent example
you had Eric Schmidt and Mark Zuckerberg
and Reed Hastings all big tech players
at the White House recently meeting with
the president and they were voicing
concern that you know that that
basically the privacy of their users was
being threatened by all of this so how
do you how do you reach that balance
where you know you have CEOs that say
okay I'm willing to turn over this
information because maybe it's critical
to our national security but at the same
time I need to protect my customer and
all this well you don't know necessarily
the personally identifiable our personal
identifiable information what you do is
you take the patterns that are
established you may see it as an ISP
particular patterns are established that
indicate wrongdoing and
you can you can cordon off that
information that should not be turned
over but there's substantial information
that can and should be turned over and
it would not be to the detriment of the
particular company because the company
can put persons in places where you
establish this kind of connectivity to
assure that that company's information
is used appropriately and by the same
token to the extent they join that they
get the benefit of the intelligence it
comes back that may and enable them to a
burden attack it doesn't seem like we're
there yet we're not idle I mean it seems
like there is this resistance how do you
how do you work through that well there
has to be something in it for them I've
got that outweighs the downsides and
their perception of theft of their
intellectual property or identifying
them as a breacher advance of the time
that they want to do it but you
structure it in such a way that it's
beneficial to them and in terms of the
intelligence they get and by the same
token they control the personnel and the
information that's put into this unified
intelligence structure okay so we'll get
there we'll get there you just hope we
get there without a catalyst along the
lines of the September 11th is that
something you worry about yes from this
everybody everything it's you know it's
a hard thing to think about because you
know 3,000 lives were lost on 9/11 but
are there events that that you worry
about that could happen from a cyber
perspective that would be catastrophic
like that well there could be in
particularly looking at the power grids
are you looking at our infrastructure
yes financially it would [ __ ] us if
there was a substantial attack on Wall
Street on the exchanges the
you know it also could lead to a loss of
lives the extent that we can be our
command and control knocked out in
Afghanistan or Iraq or someplace we're
at war and somebody is ahead of us in
terms of both intelligence and as well
as technology so that they are able to
eliminate our camp
and control and leave us defenseless
when our enemies are moving against us
brave new world director Muller thank